questo è il prodotto dovrebbe essere
cattivo non fa paura per niente
che cos'è questo
però ci proveremo nuovi stimoli gioco
sono dei nuovi occupati cattivi ci
stanno giocando tutti super popolari
adesso non vediamo l'ora di provare
prima di iniziare però volevo
ringraziarvi per tutti i bellissimi
messaggi che mi avete scritto
grazie mille davvero siete speciali io
ora sto abbastanza bene e spero di stare
bene il più a lungo possibile ma ora
mettetevi comodi lasciate un bel mi
piace pure di pop corn e iniziamo subito
l'oratore stiamo dobbiamo prendere un
bus presso sprechiamo sappiamo entra
dentro questo cerchio è sta lì sul bus
il gioco inizia tra pochi secondi fa
salire perché lo bene serve moniti bravo
rispettare l'autista autista e guarda
anche tu hai tipo una scatola si ok
forse anno andiamo in gita come vi
dicevo queste in gioco paurosa quindi
sono super curiosa di vedere come sarà
dobbiamo vogliamo mentre aspettiamo
avete notato
nuovi ore che ne sono dei biscottini
biscotti scott e ho comprato un sacco di
nuovi orecchini è in ogni video vi farò
vedere un paio di orecchini diverse
sapete che io adoro gli orecchini con le
miniature con la cover prole io adoro i
biscotti nella sana pianta rimettersi
sotto ogni video che ho avuto data agli
orecchini da 1 a 10 che voto gli date a
questi da 1 a 10 io 9 poi scopriremo il
vincitore degli orecchini mondo strano
succedendo da quale parte dobbiamo
andare non ho capito qualcuno ha girato
la fresa
ok dovevamo andare al parco giochi ma
qualcuno sempre odiato ha girato la
freccia vera stiamo andando da un'altra
parte
c'è un simbolo di pericolo
ops
ma principale è stato preso
[Musica]
si erano tutte spopolate la strada
ok benvenuti
ho bisogno del tuo aiuto ok in cosa ma
forse sono io il cattivo
lo scopriremo molto presto
i miei blocchi sono caduti
tutto quello che devi fare è trovarli e
rimetterli a posto magari legata
missione buona fortuna penso che sia
molto facile dipende anche da come
saranno i cattivi sempre dovrebbe essere
cattivo non fa paura per niente ho
trovato il bruco non me l'hanno rubato
siamo tipo in un machete più blocco ma
il prevenuto giochi benissimo
mi ricorda un po aghi vaghi è vero
perché questo si è nascosto dietro a
questa scatola dentro questo ok io ho
preso un blocco e vaccarizzo nel muro
qui è dove sono stati creati i di cosa
stanno parlando sono dei mostri tipo
videogioco tipo fiber nelle fredde
quindi degli animatronics può essere il
primo amico di blu nel 1991 ok si chiama
blu e il cattivo quindi c'è una
musichetta strano tutto
privato cielo dietro attenzione scappa e
non lo so io non lo vedo è un gigante
noi del proprio valore a tipo anni
whiteley proprio brutto cioè che ha già
è difficile essere più brutto di l'omone
infatti trovi quello che riportano al
teatro segui le frecce blu
e in effetti non ha ancora trovato
nessun blocco allora io ne ho trovato
uno l'ho già portato ne abbiamo 15 dei
24 la dobbiamo prendere ancora tanti
tipo 8 in questo muro e si è scritto
miei solo rallentato
e stato trovato qualcuno è stato trovato
dai cartelli hanno fatto ma io non ho
ancora trovato nessun blocco belle
superare per damato caffeino ci si può
poi puoi entrare dei posti hanno gusti i
premi ct e ti abbassi puoi entrare in
quei posti piccolini piccolini
si faccia a qualcuno volare
freccia blu teatro forse poi posso
trovare finalmente dei bruni se rendere
mi dice che devo andare nel teatro
quindi spostato il vero io spesso mi
porterò nella base è certo
ma hai visto questi ne abbiamo messi ma
proprio ai fatti dovete mettere lì
perché siete nascosti in una scatola è
perché quando prendi le scatole sono
talmente tanto pesanti che di rallentano
e proprio la vicina come si
è scritto come ha eliminato colto lo
slancio mamma mia che stavo scherzando
io prima ho detto che non mi facevi
paura teso cambiato
e qui sei finali ma trattate ma dietro o
non sono in un mondo strano mi sono
nascosto
mia vita per un pennuto ti puoi
nascondere dentro la scatola forse per
non farti vedere credo esiste io mi sono
nascosta dentro un armadietto
sto trovato un sacco di cose fantastiche
questo blu sembra tutto carino un
pupazzetto tenero e dolce ma che è
successo
dove mi nascondo qua ok io ho messo
un'altra scatola bravo continui mancano
16 di 24 ne abbiamo quindi vuol dire che
ne mancano ancora 8
prima 8 ho fatto male i calcoli allora
io non è ancora trovato neanche una
schiappa
che cosa erano quei rumori strani e blu
che passa chi è anno è un giocatore
cosa fa stimi che non trovo nessuna
scatola mannaggia grande e non a caso la
devo riportarla
è trovato qualcosa no ma sentono i suoni
che fa e inquietante sto esplorando un
po in giro qui non si scappa se scrivo o
dobbiamo trovare tutte le scatole che è
successo
per primi abbiamo visto scappa
credo nel caso vedete fa paura ma
preso
appena assistito la tua eliminazione da
blu è stato un po
povero mi pare mi ha preso da emma puoi
tornare nel gioco vediamo dai dai povero
vitale è stato eliminato molto male
riuscirà a trovare almeno una tappa
allora prova a cercare altre scatole a
un certo punto a me le faceva vedere
dove erano la mappa non lo so come si sa
non sono mai passata magari questi
sotterranei o che bello se un trenino
tip haghighi
che è successo
sono stati completati
speriamo che bruno non abbia ricevuto
cosa non molto per percorrere la stessa
lucchetto voi potete tornare indietro e
leggere
che cos'è questo è questa bella se
vogliono un altro cattivo così fa un
verme una lucertola non si riesce a
capire ancora riposati un po ma grazie
avrai bisogno per domani sono bravi si è
ucciso povero
nuovo che non è finito la partita ha
quindi adesso ci si può riposare forze
e poi riparte il nuovo giorno sembra che
green sia svegliato galleria nell'altro
cattivo penso che sappia che se li da
idra o non c'è bisogno di preoccuparsi
per lui e c'è
come può prendersi se non può vederti 15
sentirà come grani perché ingredienti a
kabul si sentiva se mi facesse un rumore
che anche e forse sentiva nostra volta
dottore io mi hanno eliminato questa
volta bisogna trovare i pacchi di cibo
marche mia vita sarebbe stato bravo
no non è giusto questo non è giusto
allora questo si è nascosto nella
scatola crediamo troviamo i pacchi di
cibo e se vediamo grimm rimaniamo
immobili oppure nasconde nella scatola
comodità ma tanto che non si può vedere
quindi basta che lo so ma io tu ci sono
dei rumori molto strani
insomma quelli sono in due
solo
cioè quindi ogni livello diventano poco
quindi devi stare sopra certa quanti
diventeranno benefit questo gioco si
chiama
scopo stiamo come ti chiamo amore
allora sono sei di 15 sono stati
bravissimi gli altri giocatori hanno
preso saputi se nascosta è certo mi
stava inseguendo blu
mancano ancora 9 pacchi guarda al dopo
di cibo li provo cretino cretino
finalmente tronco al cosa mangia mangia
adesso mi ritrovo la giornata altro
dovere
[Musica]
dove siamo finiti qui non avevo mai
visto questa parte non carica stava
inseguendo adoro questa mappa eli lilly
no c'era la porta non potevi entrare in
quella borsa
dopo il traguardo o no erano troppo
scappati
dovevi ascoltare dovevi scappare back
ibaf ok ragazzi torniamo asma autobus
questa volta saremo molto più pratica
troverà un sacco di più capi treno con
sacco di sake dj box noi non saremo più
schiacciati dai veri sull'autobus ma
allora io devo ancora capire come allora
convinti nascondino concili invece ti
acconci quindi primo poteva nascondere
in protezione
quando questo è sì eccoci qua
vitale siamo seduti vicini chissà se non
avesse cambiato la fine
questo secondo te ho più paura blue
green non abbiamo ancora visto gridati
vorrei vederlo non so perché c'era un
donne si fa più paura green e poi gli
altri come si chiameranno red è
questo ciò che si chiamano rainbow
france quindi vuol dire che su temi come
le colori dell'arcobaleno e poi l'ultimo
livello sarà impossibile con tutti i
colori eh sì via roberto alla ricerca
dei blocchi trovato il polipo guarda
bravo preso
così stretta dobbiamo stare vicini dove
tenne una scusa da ieri
la vendita e prendi questo pacco qui
quando lo vedeva q e adesso dove abbiamo
tutto qua dobbiamo andare nel teatro
forse di qua di seguito
qualcuno è stato trovato oggi ha
eliminato un giocatore allora forse di
quanto possiamo prendere più blocchi
ma lo sapevo quindi quando ne trovi
qualcuno trendy va bene
aiuterà blu non mi ricordo da dove si va
dove ci sono mai stata messa non
dobbiamo andare di qua di rivivere come
roma che gli anni fa guerra c'è la scala
veramente presto stare la scala come se
la brezza
ok vino bravissimo
mi sa che va vicino una secondi sei come
il bie nascondono nella scatola
ok via libera è solo nascosta
o presto per dirlo
la spagna ha scatenato era di quasi come
c'era un altro pacco lì un altro pacco
anche qui quindi l'ho visto proprio
adoravo 2
vai in a12 e ora continuiamo la nostra
return house e di 24 mi sa che ne avevo
visto uno anche qui eccolo il 2
prendilo presto ne ho presi due li vado
a portare a chi è qui vicino sanità dove
sei vi sto parlando da sola è nata a ok
perfetto qui possiamo nasconderci lo sai
privati andare adesso come
allora non era una scappatoia proviamo a
scendere qua ok ma noi siamo o non siamo
mai entrato qui cosa che tremava di
blocco viviamo
non fa ma regge niente ehi guarda se c'è
qui il guà e dove lavavano i pupazzi
cattivi vedi li legavano con le catene e
poi qua ci sono le docce sì forse sono
quasi cattivi perché li trattava male
sono anche loro degli esperimenti come a
dualchi volete fa per tutta la storia
adesso sapete che io ho dato sapere chi
guarda io
sono nella camera di controllo qui dove
sei tu ti vedo più
così dire ok qua non c'è niente con la
licenza di altri vedi qua ti dice quanti
cattivi ci saranno 3 4 5 6 7 solo un
pacco non darei il passo
ci sono dei rumori strani vabbè lascio
questo pacco in 14 dei 24 ok non tiferò
divisa tra quattro grande mancano solo
cinque pacchi dress prezzo troviamo lì
prova provata 2 bravissima le mancano
solo tre allora dovrebbe saranno i già
member nel miglior teatro prima che mi
prenda blue sea mancano solo tre gli
ultimi saranno i più difficili da
trovare
devo dire che finora mi piace questo
gioco detto a vincere soprattutto il
primo o il primo quadro
non è facile però è bello pauroso ho
appreso ha preso qualcuno ti sto
scappando che c'è si sente quello blu a
ottimo passato scritto qua nel cartello
non lasciare che brutti e bracci come
un posto stabile ho trovato un pacco
bravo gol subito sì mi manca solo uno
all'ora
ma dove sarà l'ultimo parco fondatore
davis o no ho trovato blu ho trovato ed
ascoli fermo è tutto buio quick aiuto
oh no ono stato da dare non so dove
andare né sconti dentro la scatola
presto e vero mi ero dimenticato
in cui vitale che scava c'è blu dietro
di bene quindi non ho proposto e dove
iniziato non mi ricordo forse qui forse
non salire forse ho capito per l'altro
pacco e dove vieni qui al teatro ei lo
vedi tu quel palline si trova proprio
quello che ci sono degli indie ogni
lancio si ci sono del giudizio
altrimenti uno l'ho trovato ma trova
benissimo vitale anche il vostro il
gioco devo credo vorrei tornare indietro
sui comparti prendere ok ti aspetti
qualche altro e io non mi ricordo del
teatro
blu
ok ora passiamo al secondo livello anche
con vitale si guarda sono rimasti morire
non ce la faremmo mai in tre a vincere
fa come difficile questo è io sono
rimasto bloccato nel letto
anch'io
ad ora l'aspetta primi chip che presto i
pacchi iniziamo subito a trovare il cibo
sono pronta se l'operato tribunale cibo
è bravissimo a trovare allora già ne ho
visto uno li per tale presa di noi preso
tutti qui e qui chinnappa scatta
chiedono di mettere la cremina
aiuto ama quindi è la stessa casa
ho trovato un pacco ho trovato anche un
altro pacco
da che io non mi vedo più sarà diventata
la trasparenza bisogna metterli qua i
pacchi dove c'è una specie di
distributore di grani e un distributore
di cereali sì sì qui vai vai qui mettiti
davanti vedi poi si riempie io comunque
non so perchè ma la mia visuale è
diventata in prima persona
pio v o no proprio con loro fermo ok
dalla tornata normale
allora io ho trovato altri due pacchi di
cibo te l'ho detto sono troppo bravo con
il cibo e se la possiamo fare vitale ha
un istinto naturale si tratta di cibo ne
ho già tre con me che io ne sta portando
un altro quartiere mancano quindi 10
la ricerca è questo rumore non lo so
credo sia al green
screen
non lo so però stai attenta quando
vedremo green secondo voi sono il teatro
sto lasciando questi altri pacchi di
cibo
e mancano solo quattro
e qui e qui al vetro blu blu blu che
nasconditi nasconditi si sta andando a
cercare altri pacchi non farti prendere
ok ok trovato un altro pacco 6 dai ci
siamo quasi è questo giocatore quale la
sposa dell'agri nato non sta cercando il
cibona per niente male che ci sono io
che sto prendendo tutto il cibo
e super pericoloso qualcosa che mi segue
sa mai visto green cos'è una lucertola e
tipo
non lo so un bene è un po pazza
collaborato a lungo è però siccome è
cieco
io mi sono fermata fermato pure nomi
motta
e tipo quel pokémon stick speak qualcosa
con me che mi ricordi su dovuto me
sembra che la chiamava al 9 tra nismo lo
ricordate che la sua famiglia quel
pokémon pokémon albero però non insomma
qualcosa di carino in faccia guardatevi
perché etiche se mi ricordo più dove
sono mi sono perso è però date né grain
dai allora io ne ho due pacchi con me
bravissimo tu continuerai 0
le mancano le mancano 4 io ne ho due
quindi ne mancano altri 26 crisi se n'è
andato via libera c'è più dietro di me
io nasco nidi subito per fortuna ho
fatto in tempo a scappare
comunque il più cattivo e blues cioè mi
sembra più forte fenomeno più
equa fermo mesto ma aiuta insomma la
scusa che ha preso a riferimento la foto
di dire
ok ne mancano solo due die ce la
possiamo fare e i c'è posto poi per
detrarre non minaccerà
mi ha portato
a quello nero mai entrata e non c'è un
bel niente è diciamo poi già controllato
poi non c'è niente
qualcuno ha provato a che bello siamo
rimasti solo io e te adesso il giocatore
che tanto non stavamo facendo niente non
ho più un piccolo cieco e di dove sei
non mi dire che se preso no no no no me
lo prendo subito nono si aprono con gli
armadietti ma come non sono stato a
sinistra nascosta
ok vedo vedo vedo gli indizi ceo anch'io
perfetto andiamo allora sono due vicini
si metta devo aspettare che va da via
blues dove si vede tema sono quei
pallini po stordito prendere quel
pacchetto
ci perde qui sono vicini allora tutti
quando senti verde devi stare immobile e
devi nasconderti nella scatola e lui non
ti vedrà ok io lo vedo tante cieco mi
sono nascosta nella scatola per ho paura
che stia venendo verso di me ma tanto lo
si vede
ok sta andando verso lo vede apprezzare
i due spaghetti
ai prezzi si ok a loro ci vediamo
direttamente al teatro sempre sud arriva
restare salva
sei proprio vicino si sono brava io sto
arrivando non si creda se vorresti dire
a superare blasoni poi tra l'altro dai
moti turismo verrà detto perché ogni
tanto si sente rumore
non ci convinceva paolo ii livello
adesso
orange o
arancione i cereali e unendo sopresa
anche senso orange ha lasciato la sua
caverna
cota ha sentito l'odore del cibo si sta
parlando di
amore 2
rai 2 ha superato
orange un altro mangione aver trovato
cibo quindi ora non riesce a sentire il
nostro odore invece green riesce a
sentire con l'udito e blu riesce a
vedere passare l'ultima notte
se superiamo questo livello abbiamo
vinto ma saranno
turchina ti mostrerò perché sei qui ok
ma dobbiamo farcela di quel programma
ciò che sono qua voglio scoprire tornati
quella storia perché le prese d'aria
hanno iniziato a perdere ma se sono le
prese d'aria come farla perdere che cosa
devono perdere così che i fusibili 14
possibili dobbiamo trovare bene sembra
facile ma non lo è non so neanche come
sono fatti cerchiamo di stare vicini
no forse è meglio separarsi altrimenti
non ritroveremo mai sì però un po paura
siamo i due
eccone uno brava
e tessuti
[Musica]
ei no qua non c'è niente che non i
protoni di kennedy pronto a nasconderti
che sto passando forse ora non ci
vediamo
tutti quando mettiamo carica troppo
carina della scatola qatar
ok via libera dove andiamo verso il
teatro si vota lasciare questo è
possibile
vediamo se le troviamo altri guarda un
altro palo prima
prova le mie per riportare al teatro
come in italiano li chiama mice prezzo
analizza l'ho presa
e ce n'è un altro verso che mi prendi lo
ok
ma dico altro ma questa è la strada che
abbiamo fatto prima non lo so è un pò
labirinto seta prodotta un'altra
bisogna stare molto attenti a
qualche rumor inquietante loro sono tre
noi siamo due avuto un'altra
o presso chiamare 5 cos'è questo rumore
non lo so sei
sempre che qualcuno abbia dimenticato di
gente da mangiare all'arancia che cosa
vuol dire
nasconditi che sta che sta uscendo
allora ce l'abbiamo 8 di 14 quindi ce ne
mancano solo sei ne abbiamo fatto più di
mezzo ai bravissimi
andiamoci piano piano non mi sembra di
vedere ora
forse possiamo andare
proviamo wow può venire un sacco di
hunter è vicina ma dietro veramente ho
visto qualcuno muoversi sei sicura
perché mi ha mai detto qua
ei sicuro nuovo green sento green
nasconditi
nasconditi e blu blu e blu da questa
parte grida quest'altra che protestare
perché sta avvenendo proprio verso di
noi blu no perché si è allontanato ok
anche credo mi sembra che sia da dove
possiamo andare ma stiamo di qua e booth
piangerelli cioè il film dice grimm stai
andando verso grimm e no magari non è
andato proprio no su questo
che è successo green.tv ripreso portate
diffusi quindi il nostro porta dobbiamo
per forza non c'è niente a questo è
troppo sia allora dietro questa fortezza
green ha capito che se bring
possibili però quindi deve stare che
vada via e poi entrare la des e proviamo
ad aprire la porta per vedere se ne sta
andando via
vediamo
lei li vedete sta facendo la guardia i
fusibili c'è invece se andiamo da
un'altra parte per il momento bene ma io
voglio prendere quel contenibile dove
saranno che altri dai riusciremo io e
vitale da soli abbiamo operare questo
livello facendo un ottimo lavoro già
quindi forse ce la possiamo fare
c'è da prendere da green
ma magari una scatola non è che ti
protegge da tutto tutto tutto
chiudiamo promuovere la rigenerazione
ok sono rigenerato ho dovuto spendere
dei robot riuscita attenta attenta
perché sono uscite queste lame di fuoco
qui non so che cosa sono forse sono tele
trappole sì meglio che non ci vai sopra
e come si fa non si può saltare non
passare lì finché non scompaiono
non mi sembra una cosa molto fattibile
se questo green e orange e quello
che sta avvenendo proprio qui verso di
me nasconditi è velocissimo l'avete
vista pratico una lucertola allora non
mi ha visto mi sono nascosto e non mi ha
visto lui è andato avanti però è molto
pericoloso che prova andare qua che si
fa saltare sopra queste cose mi
raccomando è stato un bel mi piace per
portarsi para forse ho capito
ho capito praticamente quando quando
vedi
nel progetto
praticamente quando vedi quelle fiamme
arancioni e il percorso che farà orange
quindi che deve nascondere
beh almeno c'è un indizio è ma mi spiego
come faccio io ora da sola ma solo a
trovare tutte le micce e non lo so
a
me sta inseguendo come vino stato o no
se solo
non ce la farò mai mi nascondo qua
eccolo che paura
io non mi ha visto
mi mancano quanti possibile per maicon 6
solo
vedere se adesso c'è poi ti aiuti non si
riesce a trovarli da qualche parte
ok devo stare dentro la scatola in
silenzio non devo muovermi
perché si muove così perché troppo
simpatico queste sono cari ecco vedi è
uscita adesso uscirà anche orange e farà
tutto quel percorso tipo una lucertola
che cambino così vediamo adesso arriva
[Musica]
ecco
carino ma sono tutti carini sono tutti
stradi però vedete che vi verrà incontro
quello con i cattivi ok finalmente sta
andando via grain comunque il più
difficile blu perché grillo lo senti
arrivare oranges invitati ma invece non
devi niente di fatto guarda sembra
credere
devo trovare temi c'è non ne ho trovato
dai dai dai dai provo a cercare meglio
da qualche altra parte dove non si è mai
andata per esempio perché questi questi
pezzi quindi abbiamo fatto mille volte e
quindi non abbiamo trovato niente dove
provenga aree insomma che mi in qualche
cos'era quel rumore però salire su qui
tanto siamo passati attentamente
avvicinare al tra le mani
questo
blu infatti diceva non avvicina
prevedere niente quindi non abbiamo
fatte volete che continuiamo il gioco e
scopriamo la verità è anche gli altri
amici o sfregiato nel redigere bof renzo
amici ma non sono amici va bene se
volete che scopriamo gli altri personali
lasciato un bel mi piace questo video è
di 5 mila mi piace faremo il consiglio e
allora vi lasciamo 4chan senza qui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri del
cazzo come preferite
ciao